in the beginning when he was trying to
groom you and like like
he told you he was treating you and
bringing you up as his own son
right was his objective to make you turn
you into a trained killer
uh no he was turning me into
again the the only way i could describe
it is
the consummate wise guy he wanted all of
his guys
when you walked into a place they know
you're a good fella
and not because you're banging the place
up or getting fights
just the way you carry yourself and the
way you talk to others
uh the way you dress you know
uh the way you tip you know there's a
whole bunch of things
and he taught me every one of those he
never walked into a restaurant where he
didn't give the maitre d
a 10. and then again this is back 30
years maybe he would give him 20 now you
know
uh i still do that you know uh person
that took me to
the to the uh table at burns i i tipped
her
i just it's just you know she walked me
to the table and she was shocked
but uh so no so you had to be
and you had to be able to kill
and hurt people when they uh
had to be hurt you know so
yeah as a grooming and and and i i i
tell you baby steps the first
hit that i was even privy to in any way
shape or form
i was asked to give a guy a flat tire
okay
he gave me the ice pick and that morning
very early in the morning i went i gave
the guy a flat
i didn't think none of it i thought it
was i is silly i thought he parked in
his
place or or in his driveway or did
something
disrespectful and he just wanted to give
the guy a flat
the next day in the newspaper man killed
fixing flat tire
so he's was shot and i didn't
say anything to greg about it i read it
i knew it i knew it was the car i gave
the flat to
but i think it was my first little test
you don't have to wear this you can take
them off you sure yeah possibly okay
yeah
uh yeah it uh that was my first test
where he if i would have came in like
panicky
or great at the same car like nervous
but i knew better and i was probably
only 20.
but i was already around these guys they
treat me like an equal
uh i go everywhere with greg he's
bringing me to meet other bosses other
captains
so i can't i just know okay a few months
later
he asked me to go buy a shovel i bite a
shovel
a couple of a year goes by six months
it's not like we're killing every day
somebody's got to go and it's tony fresa
so me and gregory
have to go buy shovels and dig a hole
okay that's what i said the hole was
already dug
okay we got the first murder you
witnessed yeah
yeah that's that would be the first one
that i was really really pretty
that i actually brought him to his
demise you know
uh but the the later on the first one
that i
i was a crash car now and uh i was right
on the scene and i saw the guy getting
popped and they jump in the car and
drive away
so that's what i'm saying you know ask
you to pull the trigger for quite a
while
until you're you've been around enough
of them that
you uh you're kind of desensitized to it
by the time you actually yeah you know
it's hard to use words uh that's a great
word to use
uh it's sad to say you know but that's a
good word you you do get desensitized
that's a great
way to put it because i fumble over that
to say how it's possible
right you know especially growing up the
way i did from a normal family
uh one of the cops on my case tommy
dave's a dear friend to this day
said in an interview you know one of
those interviews
among cops where they're trying to
figure out uh you know the mind of a
killer or whatever you want to call it
and he said he used me he says if a
sweetheart like larry massa could do it
anybody can do it so
you know it's how you brought up and and
here's the other thing you got to
realize
we're recruited at a very young age
where you're
maybe easily misled
or or uh
you like the cause you you you gravitate
you like the cadillac you like all the
money
and you don't really know
the bad side of it so you recruited at
15 16 17. i was 17. the guys that were
younger than me that were coming into
the club
my point is all these years later
they can't recruit me they ca nobody
could recruit me to do something like
that
i know better i mean i i you know i i
learned the hard way in some ways but
i i would never you know i wouldn't
i won't i you know the hitman thing is
another myth
i'm not a hitman you know the newspaper
one day
put an article out hitman
to testify against uh
g would they call him a g uh a g-man
g-man hitman to testify against g-man
because i wound up that was my saving
grace at the end
i mean i i made a deal with the
government but uh basically it was
about the corruption because all their
cases were going to get blown out of the
water
you know so uh whose cases were blown
out of the world well all the k
all the guys that were going to be going
to trial it came out now that
greg my boss was uh an informant for 30
years
so they we didn't know who it was
who he was getting information from we
thought it was either a cop or somebody
on the other side
during the war which i'll explain to you
further so
we knew there was somebody but now he
admits
fast forward while he's away
that he was work that he was a
government of former so he wanted
leniency even at the very end he wanted
leniency after all the
murders we did during the war you know
and the judge says no
can't do it not this time any sentence
in 10 years which was life for him
anyway
uh the aspirins what were they not just
not to get a headache was there anything
else
well you know we would go for a drink
every night after the club the aspers
and the liquor have a nice uh a little
no i think it's just so you know if you
drink too much you get a headache yeah
he had the aspirins first so he wouldn't
get the headache
that was his thinking i do that with
advil sometimes i wonder if it's uh
that's bad
oh you know i don't know i think it's
the aspirin itself that is very acidic
and caused these holes in his stomach so
they all burst all at the same time
anyway
he almost died and he had to get a blood
transfusion this is another story that
you can't make up
30 of us show up to give him blood
one match first of all he should have
took the hospital blood
it was screened they knew there was no
aids in it uh
and this is right at the height of aids
one match one of our guys paulie pumps
big muscle guy
he's the match he gives him the blood
it's
it's tainted with aids so greg winds up
with aids
and poorly got it from needles he was uh
steroids steroids from
they would share him yeah you know he he
uh i always say it because i
you know again it's the way things are
now it doesn't even matter but
he wasn't gay i mean he had everybody
thought it was a gay gay gay thing right
and it was for the most part right back
then
uh but he was uh he had more girls
he was polished he's the first guy that
taught me how to drink wine
and taught me about the final wines uh
so poorly uh
uh but um but but it was the vine into
intervention
that this is what god wanted for greg to
go out that way
or just dumb luck i don't know but uh
he wound up with aids and he had enough
money that he was able to survive it
because he kept using all the trial
drugs
but eventually he lost so much weight
and and the dementia was kicking in
and during the war he had dementia so we
were out
you know hunting how old was he this
time uh
probably it's funny to say it i
i gotta say early 60s really yeah
yeah because i met him he was about
51 52 when linda was 32.
he was like 20 years older than her and
this is 10 years later 60 61 years old
okay yeah that's about it yeah
so uh you know
i'm 60. so it's like you know are you
making me think about it i'm saying it's
yeah it's really
i don't feel like i'm ready to go soon
yeah you look great we're 60 man
great shape thank you appreciate that
but uh
uh so he eventually he died from that in
jail
yeah yeah uh but yeah the war was a
nightmare how long after he was in jail
that he finally died
uh probably four years he still hung on
yeah they sent him to the hospital in
springfield
uh i heard at the end he was like
literally i want to say like 50 pounds
just just really uh
you know i just thought i'd eat him up
[Laughter]